it's meant for kids boys and girls are
supposed to enjoy these things and yet
we look at them and say these are
[ __ ] inappropriate toys I'll have you
know that this week's and preparatory is
an all [ __ ] addition yeah because the
poop toys are taken over the world why
indeed thank you
a woman after my own heart why do kid
why do kids have to play with feces now
why is this the new thing whoa oh the
kids so hip now with their puka shells
and their lava lamps and their beanbag
chairs now they got to play with the
poop it was adorable - here you go
why hoping that others would join you're
like I'm alone no I'm not because people
are up in arms this week they had the
New York Toy Fair I guess it was yes
only in a week and they said the floor
was just covered with poop game [ __ ]
games no actually yes of course actual
games based all on [ __ ] and I don't
understand why our next generation of
children is so fascinated with feces I
don't get a G dude like you know okay
this mainstream now now it's poop poop
belongs in the toilet Kevin yes I will
never I will die on this hill poop
belongs in the toilet not in the hands
of our children fair enough
so this week it's all about the poop
toys Rob in Nebraska sent this one and
he said as a seven-year-old my seven
year old we're shopping at Target we
came upon this gym not sure what's
inside but I'm hoping it's a lighter in
a direction to Bieber's house he wrote
it's just a bag that says poop the game
warning this package contains poop
actually it's a card game called poop ah
and here's how you play the card game
here's a little video tutorial poop the
game is a card game for two to five
players while you'll be playing one card
at a time and trying to be the first one
to run out of all your cards but watch
out if you're the one that makes the
number equal or be greater than the
toilet you'll end up clogging it up and
having to take all these cards back in
your hand
you clog the toilet with your [ __ ] and
you have to take all the cards back so
it's kind of like playing uno but it's
puno yeah and the cart each card has oh
here's four it's got four turds on it
and then the card with the three turds
has like corn kernels in the turrets the
[ __ ] is wrong with you people
why aren't you upset by this oh you clog
the toilet grab all your [ __ ] go back to
start [ __ ] you poop creator this is
madness it's kind of homegrown man you
can see like that was the creator of the
game the guy himself yeah good idea he
was like I like my game of poop I bet he
does who wants to play poop with me man
Gary Fisher from Sydney Australia it's
not just our problem it's worldwide you
people are missing out pay attention
Sydney Australia they've got a poop
problem - he said we found this at a
bookshop here in Sydney Gary Road it's
it's a different take on poop it's the
magical poo make your own magical poo
and at least they sell it on the box
punch it on that - unicorn by the way
yeah their place you'd understand where
the poos coming out of the unicorn they
sit [ __ ] just flying out of the [ __ ]
of a unicorn on the box Oh what should I
do with that poo that flies out of the
[ __ ] the unicorn my god I tell you it
says right there in the box put in your
head and just have it drip through your
[ __ ] hand where your a corn [ __ ] all
over your hand you Australian child did
you see the expression on the unicorns
face yeah look here here's my [ __ ]
sharing it like Oh Robbie unicorn you're
lucky to have my magical poo I don't
think I've ever looked that relaxed
taking a [ __ ] like that - it was like
hey man he looks stoned when I'm taking
a [ __ ] I'm like wow magically I don't
also crap in children's hands and oh
that's not since the court order no not
anymore
and lastly this one came right from the
floor of the New York toy show this came
in from Bobby Clarke in the back of my
mind I'm hoping it's the Bobby Clarke he
said I can't wait to play with this
shitty toy it is called Flushing frenzy
it is a game we got the box there yeah
holy [ __ ] that is egregiously nutty [ __ ]
it comes with a plunger and a toilet and
a real-life turd and you play the flush
in frenzy whoever has to plunge the
toilet you got to catch the [ __ ] when it
flies out of the photo
ah but don't take my word for it here's
one of the the spokespeople for flushing
frenzy showing you how it's played you
plunge the toilet yeah she actually gets
[ __ ] worn out she's gonna switch
hands alright start again yeah wait wait
oh oh the [ __ ] came out and I caught it
so I get two tokens [ __ ] hits the floor
and I pick up the [ __ ] I only get one
token you filthy [ __ ] that made this
game I also don't think they understand
plumbing the [ __ ] doesn't go into the
back upper Decker upper Decker is it
upper Decker that true those yeah so
only if you want to ruin someone's night
[Music]
you
[Music]